del lado izquierdo tenemos la proyección
de fisher que es otra forma de
representar una molécula fisher llegó a
esto cuando trabajaba con carbohidratos
incluso ganó el premio nobel de química
observen que donde se cruzan estas
líneas tenemos un carbono es un centro
quiral porque tenemos cuatro grupos
diferentes unidos a este carbono
miren tenemos un hidrógeno 1 h un
aldehído y un c h 2 h en esta imagen
podemos ver el carbono y en esta
fotografía de la derecha
este es nuestro centro que irá el
carbono ahora las líneas horizontales
significan que el enlace se encuentra
hacia nosotros por ejemplo esta línea
indica que el enlace sale de la página
hacia nosotros y lo podemos representar
con una cuña así que este hidrógeno se
encuentra hacia nosotros espero que
puedan verlo y lo mismo ocurre con esta
línea horizontal del
este es un enlace que se encuentra hacia
nosotros así que lo representamos con
una cuña y miren aquí tenemos el lo h
hacia nosotros ahora una línea vertical
significa que el enlace se aleja de
nosotros por ejemplo esta línea
significa que el enlace con él ha leído
se aleja de nosotros y por eso lo
podemos representar con una línea
punteada y claro en la fotografía
podemos ver que este enlace se encuentra
lejos de nosotros y lo mismo ocurre con
esta línea vertical del ch 2 o h eso
significa que el enlace se aleja de
nosotros así que lo representamos con
una línea punteada el enlace se aleja de
nosotros
ahora si queremos saber cuál es la
configuración del centro que ir al bueno
existen muchos métodos que podemos usar
yo les mostraré los dos que más me gusta
una forma es pensar en la prioridad de
estos cuatro grupos sabemos por los
vídeos anteriores que el hidrógeno tiene
menor prioridad y en este caso tenemos
el grupo de menor prioridad hacia
nosotros así que tenemos que ver la
molécula desde esta perspectiva para
poder ver el centro giral desde aquí
porque desde esta perspectiva el
hidrógeno está lejos de nosotros veamos
rápidamente un vídeo para visualizar
mejor todo esto aquí tenemos el centro
quiral podemos ver 1h hacia nosotros un
hidrógeno hacia nosotros un aldehído
lejos de nosotros y un ch todos
lejos de nosotros pero si observamos el
centro quiral desde aquí rotar e la
molécula ahora podemos ver qué
o h se encuentra hacia nosotros y el
hidrógeno está lejos de nosotros después
tenemos el aldehído hacia abajo y hacia
la derecha y nuestros h2oh se encuentra
hacia abajo y hacia la izquierda vamos a
dibujar lo que vimos en el vídeo aquí
tenemos la fotografía empecemos con el
centro girar aquí tenemos el carbón
después tenemos 1h hacia nosotros
pongamos una cuña o h y miren ahora el
hidrógeno está lejos de nosotros así que
lo podemos representar con una línea
punteada por otro lado el aldehído se
encuentra hacia abajo y hacia la derecha
pero podemos decir que se encuentra en
el plano entonces vamos a dibujarlo con
una línea pondré el doble enlace con el
oxígeno y también tenemos el ch 2h hacia
abajo y hacia la derecha
así que pondré el carro
o no con dos hidrógenos y después el h
por acá ok ahora asignemos la prioridad
a los cuatro grupos
este es nuestro centro que irá y los
elementos unidos directamente al centro
quiral son el hidrógeno un oxígeno un
carbono y otro carbono bueno sabemos que
el oxígeno tiene el número atómico más
alto de todos estos átomos así que el h
es el número uno mientras que el
hidrógeno como tiene el número atómico
más pequeño tiene la prioridad más baja
es el número cuatro después tenemos dos
carbonos que tienen el mismo número
atómico pero para saber quién gana hay
que analizar a que están unidos
esos carbonos bueno el carbono de la
izquierda está unido a un oxígeno y dos
hidrógenos entonces oxígeno hidrógeno
hidrógeno mientras que el carbono de la
derecha está
con un doble enlace a un oxígeno y en
vídeos anteriores dijimos que esto es
como si tuviéramos un carbono unido a
todos oxígenos aunque en realidad
sabemos que es un doble enlace y bueno
este carbono también está unido a un
hidrógeno entonces aquí tenemos oxígeno
oxígeno e hidrógeno
lo escribiré oxígeno oxígeno hidrógeno
vamos a ver aquí tenemos oxígeno y
oxígeno pero después tenemos oxígeno y
acá tenemos hidrógeno obviamente el
oxígeno gana así que como este grupo
gana el aldehído tiene mayor prioridad
que el ch 2 h
entonces el aldehído es el número 2 y el
ch 2 h es el número 3 y como el
hidrógeno ya está lejos de nosotros no
tenemos que preocuparnos por eso y
simplemente seguimos el orden
un círculo que pase por 1 2 y 3 observen
que nos movemos en esta dirección que es
la misma en la que se mueven las
manecillas del reloj así que la
configuración es r la configuración del
centro girar es
me gustaría hacer un paréntesis para
mostrarles cómo pasar de este dibujo a
lo que tenemos en la fotografía como el
hidrógeno se encuentra de este lado
queremos ver la molécula desde esta
perspectiva para que el hidrógeno quede
lejos de nosotros y así podamos ver el
centro quiral desde arriba a mí me gusta
imaginar que este carbono se encuentra
en el plano es decir aquí tenemos el
centro quiral pero imaginen que tenemos
una hoja de papel que pasa a través del
centro gira ahora sabemos que lo h se
encuentra hacia arriba porque está
representado con una cuña entonces si
observamos la molécula desde esta
perspectiva el h debe estar hacia arriba
en relación a la hoja de papel y miren
precisamente se encuentra hacia arriba
ahora él aldehído se encuentra hacia
abajo porque está representado con esta
línea punteada y nos
queda del lado derecho si nuestros ojos
se encuentran aquí entonces el aldehído
se encuentra hacia abajo respecto a la
hoja de papel hacia abajo y hacia la
derecha este sería el aldehído mientras
que de este lado que sería el lado
izquierdo el ch 2 o h también se
encuentra hacia abajo pero en este caso
sería hacia abajo y hacia la izquierda
aquí podemos ver el pse h2oh hacia abajo
y hacia la izquierda y bueno una vez que
ya tenemos la molécula así es mucho más
fácil asignar la configuración del
centro girar bueno este fue el primer
método el segundo método creo que es más
fácil ya sabemos que el grupo o h tiene
la prioridad número uno el aldehído es
el número todos el ch todos o h es el
número tres y el hidrógeno tiene el
número cuatro
entonces el truco es ignorar
hidrógeno se encuentra hacia nosotros y
eso lo sabemos porque esta línea
horizontal de la proyección de fisher se
simboliza con una cuña entonces solo
ignoremos al hidrógeno y veamos los
grupos 1 2 y 3 al pasar de 1 a 2 y a 3
podemos ver que nos movemos en esta
dirección es decir a contrareloj
entonces parece que la configuración es
s parece s pero miren como el hidrógeno
se encuentra hacia nosotros el truco es
que la configuración real es contraria a
lo que parece así que en realidad la
conformación es r
este truco siempre funciona cuando
trabajamos con proyecciones de fisher
existen muchas formas de hacer esto y
claro es más fácil si tienen un modelo
molecular y tratan de encontrar la que
funcione mejor para ustedes
finalmente dibujemos el enantiómero de
este compuesto el método del espejo
funciona muy bien al trabajar con
proyecciones de fisher del lado
izquierdo tenemos el modelo de nuestro
compuesto y del lado derecho tenemos su
reflejo o proyección especular observen
que el h se refleja en el espejo
entonces vamos a dibujar una línea para
representar el espejo y ahora vamos a
reflejar hilo h
del otro lado del espejo después vamos a
dibujar una línea horizontal que
representa estos 12 enlaces
y después tenemos un hidrógeno del lado
derecho tenemos una línea vertical vamos
a dibujarla y arriba tenemos un aldehído
vamos a ponerlo ahí está finalmente
tenemos el ch 2 o h abajo entonces ch
todos o h
ahora el compuesto inicial solo tiene un
centro quiral que sería este y miren
aquí tenemos el centro girar del
enantiómero este es el único centro que
irak así que no tenemos que preocuparnos
por el aldehído o el ch 2h al reflejar
esta molécula pero asegúrense de que
están dibujando el reflejo aquí en lo h
está del lado derecho y en el
enantiómero del lado izquierdo
nuestro objetivo es invertir la
configuración del centro girar